[Music]
reinvention means to me doing something
out of the ordinary I was just trying to
find a way to revolve the position and
how people view football players from an
intellectual standpoint we were last
mortared feed us pray
[Music]
from a football standpoint I think guys
need to put a little more energy into
understanding the business and I think
that's the thing understanding what
actually goes into a contract
understanding the things that they try
to hide from during the contract and
paying teach those things I think just
being more active and involved in that
process can can teach you a lot because
when we get into the game up there like
everybody runs to get a financial
advisor without learning how money works
and they put all their trust into an
agent that they just met and so
understanding that life doesn't have to
go that fast you can slow down and I
really take the time to learn the
business that you in so it doesn't get
over me I learned a lot from Richard
Sherman and Russel Kuhn when I watched
them kind of go through and and do that
process I learned that media plays a big
role in the narrative and so sometimes
you need to get ahead of the narrative
because if you don't you let somebody
else tell your story for you before you
get a chance to tell it so I think in
both their situations I felt like there
were people behind the scenes trying to
create a narrative hoping players
wouldn't have the confidence to go do a
concert themselves but you know I feel
like it's a big enough industry that
everybody can
I'm hoping that I inspire more guys to
understand the business at the hint you
know we hear so many crazy stories about
guys coming to lead and losing all their
money and so we got to learn from that
and we got to learn from everybody that
came before us and a way to learn is to
learn the business and that's what we
need to take more pride into is learning
the business and learning not just
what's on the football field but what
sawed off the football field
you